[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a book named caroline
and it's going to be read for you
by me and by some of my friends
and i'm neil gaiman and i wrote it
and it begins like this
fairy tales are more than true
not because they tell us that dragons
exist but because they tell us that
dragons can be beaten
gk chesterton chapter one
caroline discovered the door a little
while after they moved into the house
it was a very old house it had an attic
under the roof
and a cellar under the ground and an
overgrown garden
with huge old trees in it caroline's
family
didn't own all of the house it was too
big for that
instead they owned part of it there were
other people who lived in the old house
miss [ __ ] and miss forcible lived in
the flat below coral lines on the ground
floor
they were both old and round and they
lived in their flat with a number of
aging highland terriers who had names
like hamish and andrew
and jock once upon a time miss pink and
miss forcible
had been actresses as miss pink told
caroline
the first time she met her you see
caroline miss pink said getting
coraline's name wrong
both myself and miss forcible were
famous actresses in our
time we trod the boards lovey oh don't
let hamish eat the fruitcake or he'll be
up all night with his tummy
it's coraline not caroline
coraline said coraline
in the flat above caroline's under the
roof
was a crazy old man with a big moustache
he told coraline that he was training a
mouse
circus he wouldn't let anyone see it
one day little caroline when they are
all ready
everyone in the whole world will see the
wonders of my mouse circus
you ask me why you cannot see it now is
that what you asked me
no said coraline quietly i asked you not
to call me
caroline it's caroline
the reason you cannot see the mouse
circus
said the man upstairs is that the mice
are not yet ready and rehearsed
also they refuse to play the songs i
have written for them
all the songs i have written for the
mice to play go um
but the white mice will only play
toodle-oodle
like that i am thinking of trying them
on different types of cheese
caroline didn't think there really was a
mouse circus
she thought the old man was probably
making it up
the day after they moved in caroline
went exploring
she explored the garden it was a big
garden
at the very back was an old tennis court
but no one in the house played tennis
and the fence around the court had holes
in it and the net had mostly rotted away
there was an old rose garden filled with
stunted fly blown rose brushes
there was a rockery that was all rocks
there was a fairy ring
made of squidgy brown toadstools which
smelled dreadful
if you accidentally trod on them there
was also a well
on the first day caroline's family moved
in miss [ __ ] and miss forcible made a
point
of telling caroline how dangerous the
well was
and they warned her to be sure she kept
away from it
so caroline set off to explore for it so
that she knew where it was
to keep away from it properly
she found it on the third day in an
overgrown meadow beside the tennis court
behind a clump of trees
a low brick circle almost hidden in the
high grass
the well had been covered up by wooden
boards to stop anyone falling in
there was a small knot hole in one of
the boards and caroline spent an
afternoon dropping
pebbles and acorns through the hole and
waiting and
counting until she heard the plop as
they hit the water far below
caroline also explored for animals she
found a hedgehog
and a snakeskin but no snake and a rock
that looked just like a frog and a toad
that looked just like a rock there was
also a haughty black
cat who sat on walls and tree stumps and
watched her
but slipped away if ever she went over
to try to play with it
that was how she spent her first two
weeks in the house
exploring the garden and the grounds
her mother made her come back inside for
dinner and for lunch
and caroline had to make sure she
dressed up warm before she went out for
it was a very cold
summer that year but go out she did
exploring every day until the day it
rained
when caroline had to stay inside
what should i do ask caroline
read a book said her mother watch a
video
play with your toys go and pester miss
[ __ ] or misforcible
or the crazy old man upstairs no
said coraline i don't want to do those
things
i want to explore i don't really mind
what you do
said coraline's mother as long as you
don't make a mess
caroline went over to the window and
watched the rain come down
it wasn't the kind of rain you could go
out in it was the other kind
the kind that threw itself down from the
sky and splashed where it landed
it was rain that meant business
and currently its business was turning
the garden into a wet
muddy soup caroline had watched all the
videos
she was bored with her toys and she'd
read all her books
she turned on the television she went
from channel to channel to channel but
there was nothing on but men in suits
talking about the stock market
and talk shows finally
eventually she found something to watch
it was the last half of a natural
history program about something called
protective coloration she watched
animals
birds and insects which disguise
themselves as leaves or twigs or other
animals to escape from things that could
hurt them
she enjoyed it but it ended too soon
and was followed by a program about a
cake factory
it was time to talk to her father
caroline's father was home both of her
parents worked
doing things on computers which meant
that they were home
a lot of the time each of them had their
own study
hello caroline he said when she came in
without turning around
said coraline it's raining
yup said her father it's bucketing down
no said caroline it's just raining can i
go outside
what does your mother say she says
you're not going out in weather like
that coraline jones
then no but i want to carry on exploring
explore the flat suggested her father
look
here's a piece of paper and a pen count
all the doors and windows
list everything blue mount an expedition
to discover the hot water tank
and leave me alone to work
can i go into the drawing room the
drawing room
was where the joneses kept the expensive
and uncomfortable
furniture coraline's grandmother had
left them when she died caroline wasn't
allowed in there
nobody went in there it was only for
best
if you don't make a mess and you don't
touch anything
caroline considered this carefully then
she took the paper
and pen and went off to explore the
inside of the flat
she discovered the hot water tank it was
in a cupboard
in the kitchen she counted everything
blue
153 she counted the windows
21 she counted the doors
14. at the doors that she found
13 opened and closed the other
the big carved brown wooden door at the
far corner of the drawing room
was locked she said to her mother
where does that door go nowhere
it has to go somewhere her mother shook
her head look she told caroline
she reached up and took a string of keys
from the top of the kitchen door frame
she sorted through them carefully and
selected the oldest
biggest blackest rustiest key
they went into the drawing room she
unlocked the door with the key
the door swung open her mother was right
the door didn't go anywhere it opened
onto a brick wall
when this place was just one house said
caroline's mother
that door went somewhere when they
turned the house into flats they simply
ripped it up
the other side is the empty flat on the
other side of the house the one that's
still for sale
she shut the door and put the string of
keys back on top of the kitchen door
frame
you didn't lock it said coraline
her mother shrugged why should i lock it
she asked it doesn't go anywhere
caroline didn't say anything it was
nearly dark outside now
and the rain was still coming down
patterning against the windows and
blurring the lights of the cars and the
street outside
coraline's father stopped working and
made them all dinner
caroline was disgusted daddy
she said you've made a recipe again
it's leek and potato stew with a
tarragon garnish
and melted gruyere cheese he admitted
caroline sighed then she went to the
freezer
and got out some microwave chips and a
microwave mini pizza
you know i don't like recipes she told
her father
while her dinner went around and around
and the little red numbers on the
microwave oven counted down to zero
if you tried it maybe you'd like it
said caroline's father that she shook
her head
that night caroline lay awake in her bed
the rain had stopped and she was almost
asleep when something went
she sat up in bed something went crazy
got out of bed and looked down the hall
but saw nothing strange
she walked down the hall from her
parents bedroom came a low snoring
that was her father and an occasional
sleeping mutter
that was her mother caroline wondered if
she dreamed it
whatever it was something moved
it was little more than a shadow and it
scuttled down the darkened hall fast
like a little patch of night she hoped
it wasn't a spider
spiders made caroline intensely
uncomfortable
the black shape went into the drawing
room and carline followed it a little
nervously
the room was dark the only light came
from the hall
and caroline who was standing in the
doorway cast a huge and distorted shadow
onto the drawing room carpet
she looked like a thin giant woman
caroline was just wondering whether or
not she ought to turn on the lights
when she saw the black shape edge slowly
out from beneath the sofa
it paused and then dashed silently
across the carpet toward the farthest
corner of the room
there was no furniture in that corner of
the room
caroline turned on the light
there was nothing in the corner nothing
but the old door that opened onto the
brick wall
she was sure that her mother had shut
the door but now
it was ever so slightly open just a
crack
coraline went over to it and looked in
there was nothing there
just a wall built of red bricks
caroline closed the old wooden door
turned out the light
and went to bed she dreamed of black
shapes that slid from place to place
avoiding the light until they were all
gathered together under the moon
little black shapes with little red eyes
and sharp yellow teeth
they started to sing we are small but
we are many we are many
we are small we were here before you
rose
we will be here when you fall
their voices were high and whispering
and slightly whiny they made coraline
feel uncomfortable
then coraline dreamed a few commercials
and after that
she dreamed of nothing at all
you